(water running)
- This feels very intimate.
I would think, of all the
BuzzFeed videos I've done,
I've never brought you
guys inside my shower.
(rock music)
- I was sitting at the bar the other day,
and this girl was telling me
that she was very stressed out
so she had an orange in the shower
which completely took me by surprise.
And I was very intrigued by it.
And, apparently, last year
people were doing this.
There was a lot of articles
talking about this,
so I figured, why don't
we actually try it?
- I've never heard of this,
but I'm very excited to do
it because I love oranges.
I love citrus.
I also love hot showers.
- I've done a shower
tea, which is very nice,
just having a nice warm tea in the shower.
I've also taken like
eucalyptus essential oil
and just dropped it in my shower,
and that is actually very pleasant.
- I definitely think
this is going to be weird
because I just like to go
in my shower really quick,
do my thing, and then leave.
Especially because I'll
be eating an orange
which I don't like to eat anyways.
- I'll buy into any,
like, self-care bullshit
'cause I'm like basic ass white girl.
But, like, what is this supposed to do?
(rock music)
- Ideally, first thing in the morning,
grab the orange from the
fridge, so it has to be cold.
- Get the hot shower
ready, which is no problem.
- With the water running over you,
begin to peel the orange with your hands.
- Do not worry about the
juices getting on you.
Be messy, actually.
Oh.
- Let's do this, question mark.
- I'm grabbing my cold
orange from the fridge,
I'm getting the shower nice and warm.
- Okay,
(water running)
doing it.
- Ah, fuck.
- There is something very satisfying about
peeling something
and just throwing the rinds down.
(water running)
(cheerful music)
- Oh, smells instantly
much better in here.
And my shower already smells pretty good.
(water running)
- I know I'm supposed to peel the orange,
but my other hand is holding the phone,
so I think I'm just
gonna like pack it off.
(water running)
(cheerful music)
- The contrast of the cold orange
and the warm shower is very pleasant.
- Really messy, like, the
juice is running down my arms,
but because I'm in the shower,
I don't care about being messy.
I can just rinse it off.
- Mmmmm.
(water running)
- I did it.
(cheerful music)
- Hmmm.
- Completely unchanged.
I feel neither sexy or relaxed.
I just feel full.
- I thought it was a pretty
cool activity, however,
I wouldn't do that often
because it felt like a waste of water
and then I had to clean
up the orange peels
and that sorta thing.
Other than that, I thought
it was pretty cool,
and I did find it to be very relaxing.
- I actually really enjoyed
having that citrus smell
while I was peeling the
orange in the shower.
It was very soothing, very
relaxing to have that smell.
- Feels like you're eating
an orange in the shower.
There wasn't anything
transcendent about that for me.
I mean it's kind of cool
to have something like cold
in a hot shower, I guess,
but like that's pretty minor.
- I like it, and I would try it again.
- I'm actually very
curious to try it again,
but with another fruit that I like.
Since I am not crazy about oranges,
I think I'll like this a lot better
while I'm eating a
strawberry or raspberry.
(upbeat music)
(whip lash)
(squeaking)